ich bin gesund ich habe brunner
überstanden und das trotz meines ausmaß
doch während meiner zeit im bett und
jetzt nach den ersten tagen in freiheit
ist mir noch mal einiges klar geworden
zum spannungsfeld zwischen
freiheitsrechten demokratie und
wissenschaft denn diese pandemie ist
offenbar auf eine zutiefst gespaltene
gesellschaft gestoßen das heißt nichts
gutes für die zukunft die folgen der
pandemie und für die wissenschaft aber
vielleicht können wir doch daraus lernen
und klicks und science im future games
dreimal die woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocken nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen ich hatte
übrigens einen sehr leichten verlauf was
wahrscheinlich an meinem asthma lag denn
jeden morgen und jeden abend innerlich
einen kortison inhalt und das scheint ja
das enzym in der lunge deutlich zu
reduzieren ac2 dass das saas kopf 2
virus braucht um an menschlichen zellen
andocken zu können also kein husten
schnupfen geschmacks und geruchssinn
behalten nur diese etwas seltsam
kopfschmerzen bei denen man genau spürt
in welchem teil des gehirns das virus
gerade aktiv ist der spuk aber eben
harmlos ich habe mich geschont und nicht
wie günther jauch noch weiter meinen job
gemacht hat er dann ja auch bereut dass
es war wirklich keine gute idee hier war
es allerdings eine gute idee mich von
themen von astro comics tv vertreten zu
lassen habe ich jedenfalls den eindruck
schreibt gerne mal hier unter das video
wie er seinen job aus eurer sicht
gemacht hat vielen dank dafür auf jeden
fall an ihn zum thema an meinem ersten
tag in der ich die quarantäne verlassen
dürfte vielmehr diese überschrift aus
meinem briefkasten entgegen und ehrlich
gesagt ich dachte ich sähe nicht recht
bisher hatte ich die zeit als seriöse
wochenzeitung wahrgenommen aber wenn der
fehler schon in der überschrift steckt
der einspruch der künstler was bitte
haben ausgerechnet künstler dazu zu
sagen menschen die auf der
intensivstation arbeiten vielleicht
fachleute aus der biologie der
epidemiologie einfach leute vom fach
aber auch schon die frage an diese leute
die überhaupt keine ahnung haben können
sind wir zur wissenschafts gläubig
ehrlich gesagt
das ist kokolores auf bild zeitungs
niveau so etwas wie wissenschafts
gläubigkeit existiert nicht denn glauben
kann man nicht an wissen wissen erwirbt
man auch die zeit hat es alleine mit
diesem abstrusen ansatz dieses
dreiergespräch geschafft sich zur
steigbügelhalterin der quer denkenden zu
machen mit solchen grundsätzlichen ja
absoluten denkfehler und wenn man das
abgedruckte gespräch dann liest dann
rollen sich einem die fußnägel hoch es
ist wirklich hanebüchen wie hier
offenbar unbeleckt von jeglichem
verständnis von wissenschaft spekuliert
und fabuliert wird wissenschaft ist
nicht die sache von kunstschaffenden
dass es auch überhaupt kein problem aber
wenn man keine ahnung hat sollte man den
mund halten denn genau das ist das
prinzip von wissenschaft sollte es
jedenfalls sein denn die drei sitzen
jeweils unterschiedlich den
unterschiedlichsten fehler namen auf
aber auch der autor glänzt durch
ahnungslosigkeit kommen wir also ein
paar wirklich schlimmen drohungen aus
diesem artikel ich möchte mich vor allem
auf das krude wissenschaftsverständnis
konzentrieren aber bei einem politisch
oder juristischen thema möchte ich doch
auch noch mal einspruch erheben da wird
immer wieder mit dem begriff des
ausnahmezustands ja man muss sagen
gezündet da fabuliert die studierte
juristin juli zeh tatsächlich etwas von
einem ausnahmezustand dieser begriff ist
in diesem zusammenhang komplett falsch
und ehrlich gesagt sehe ich ihn als
politische brandstiftung und es ist
nicht mehr weit entfernt von der
angeblichen corona diktatur die gerne
von den quer denken denn herbeigeredet
wird das ist einfach nicht zutreffend
hier gibt es weder eine diktatur noch
einen ausnahmezustand das ist falsch und
eine lüge verschiedene grundrechte sind
eingeschränkt ja aber ehrlich gesagt das
findet alles in einem eng und konkret
abgesteckten rahmen statt und es
funktioniert ja und es wurde
demokratisch entschieden durch die
mehrheit den gott sei dank gehören die
drei nicht zur mehrheit denn die sie
durchaus ein dass wir handeln müssen um
die todesraten niedrig zu halten denn
und da sind wir wieder beim thema das
ich immer nur gebetsmühlen
artig wieder und wieder holen kann das
wachstum von corona ist exponentiell
und wenn der autor adam soboczynski die
hongkong-grippe anführt bei der in den
jahren 1968 bis 1970 zwei millionen
menschen weltweit starben dann ist das
nicht im entferntesten mit dieser
pandemie vergleichbar diese pandemie ist
eine noch nie da gewesene in der
geschichte der menschheit und sie wird
in den nächsten jahren noch sehr viel in
unserem täglichen leben verändern
weltweit denn an oder mit einem ziemlich
überflüssige unterscheidung übrigens 19
starben bis jetzt trotz strenger
weltweiter lockt 1 3 millionen menschen
hochgerechnet auf die weltbevölkerung
sind das rund 160 millionen tote die
eine ungebremste corona pandemie
bedeuten würde also für deutschland
wären das mehr als eine million tote wie
gesagt wenn sie ungebremst wäre die
pandemie in jeder familie gebe es dann
opfer zu beklagen ich verstehe es
vollkommen dass menschen wie juli zeh
die sich als ausgesprochene
demokratinnen verstehen probleme damit
haben dass in dieser zeit die
grundrechte der bürgerinnen und bürger
eingeschränkt werden aber hier mit
politischer agitation und dinge einfach
falsch zu betiteln das ist simpel und
einfach nicht okay und noch mal
diese rechte sind zeitlich begrenzt und
beschränkt auf ganz bestimmtes verhalten
dass die pandemie erwiesenermaßen weiter
treiben würde also legitim und
legitimiert und einmal gesagt sieht sich
dieser begriff des ausnahmezustands dann
bis zum ende dieses gesprächs dass es
ehrlich gesagt unaufrichtig und
gefährlich und es zeigt den riss der aus
meiner sicht durch die gesellschaft geht
auf der einen seite eine minderheit
allerdings sind es nicht wenige die
egoistisch drauf waren nicht zum
gesundheitsschutz beitragen zu wollen
und eine mehrheit die das versteht und
bereit ist seine opfer zu bringen um
menschenleben zu schützen und ich habe
noch nicht ganz raus woran das liegt ist
es ein intellektuelles problem sind die
menschen also ungebildet zu dumm ihnen
fehlt bestimmtes wissen allein die frage
ob wir zu wissenschafts gläubig sein das
ist echt eine schwierige frage also eine
unmögliche frage da könnte man ja gleich
fragen ob
wir uns lieber sagen lassen was ist das
für eine unwürdige frage und das auf der
titelseite derzeit blamieren aber
richtig aber mit dieser absurden frage
sind wir auch schon bei der wissenschaft
und da gibt es erhebliche
verständnisprobleme bei den dreien das
fängt an mit der sehr unscharfen und
missverständlichen äußerungen dass es
die wissenschaft gar nicht gebe
das trifft so einfach nicht zu natürlich
ist wissenschaft immer ein wettstreit
der erkenntnisse der beläge und der
datengrundlage aber und das ist ein
fettes aber immer stellt sich früher
oder später eine gut belegte erkenntnis
ein und dann gibt es eben nur noch die
gut belegte wissenschaftliche und
gültige erkenntnis um verzeihung die
gibt es bei corona bereits und wenn es
eine glasklare erkenntnis gibt dann ist
es die das lockt downs wirken und wegen
des risses solche gesellschaft sind die
wenn sie effektiv sein sollen mit
ausgangssperren verbunden dabei geht es
nicht darum dass wir nicht draußen
rumlaufen sondern dass wir uns dann wenn
geselliges beisammensein also nach 22
uhr ohne mindestabstand mit alkohol
gerne praktiziert wird dass das so
effektiv durch eine ausgangssperre
unterbunden wird und wir sehen es jetzt
wieder der locker und wirkt und zwar
sofort wie übrigens auch der erste mal
wieder durch den egoistischen teil
unserer gesellschaft auch sofort wirkt
und hier in berlin neukölln die
incidents wieder nach oben schnellt wir
waren hier auf einem guten weg in
neukölln unter die 100 und jetzt ist das
wieder mit 175 weit entfernt danke an
den ego teil unserer gesellschaft dafür
und dann wieder schweden aus dem hut zu
zaubern in diesem gespräch
es ist zum fremdschämen und wenn daniel
kehlmann dann neben den skandinaviern
noch die schweiz als leuchtendes
beispiel nennt dann verliere ich
wirklich den glauben an die menschheit
schweden 40 prozent mehr tote schweiz 25
prozent und diese länder sind nicht eng
besiedelten deutschland könnte eine
solche verfehlte politik schnell auf 100
mehr opfer hinauslaufen denn noch mal
zur erinnerung die solche verläuft
exponentiell und das würde zum
überlaufen der intensivstation führen
und damit zu deutlich mehr toten
dass das einfach nicht in die köpfe so
mancher menschen will und es ist einfach
nicht okay wenn thea dorn und daniel
kehlmann hier die
entscheidungsgrundlagen in fragen
stellen wenn kehlmann behauptet dass die
schlimmsten voraussagen von virologen
nicht eingetreten sein
dann ist das wirklich ein
intellektuelles problem sie sind sogar
immer exakt eingetreten und jeweils ende
2020 und auch jetzt im april konnte die
entwicklung nur durch einen konsequenten
lockdown gestoppt werden das sind
wirklich behauptung die da aufgestellt
werden die nah an der lüge sind und
zumindest als autor gut da hat er keine
ahnung aber als redaktionsleitung wäre
man verpflichtet das zu überprüfen
die redaktion hat sich hier es einfach
zu einfach gemacht und sich hinter der
form des interviews versteckt weil man
die aussagen ja dann nicht verantworten
müsse presserechtlich ist es vielleicht
so aber es ist in diesem fall da auch
keinerlei einordnung stattfindet
ziemlich und journalistisch und
unprofessionell und man macht sich
gemein mit querdenken dann alles dicht
machen usw dem anderen teil dem ego teil
und dann noch etwas zu wissenschaft und
ein verständnisproblem wenn kehlmann
sich hier beschwert dass der virologe
alexander kekulé seit anfang der
pandemie in seinen einschätzungen fast
immer recht gehabt hätte aber die
politik in hartnäckig ignoriert dann
klafft hier einfach eine massive
wissenslücke unabhängig davon dass
kekulé aussagen nicht selten einfach
falsch waren kehlmann hat offensichtlich
nicht das geringste verständnis von
wissenschaft und hat sich alleine mit
dieser aussage als gesprächspartner zur
corona disqualifiziert will man
wissenschaft beurteilen muss man immer
auch überprüfen ob es sich wirklich um
wissenschaft handelt von den flach
händlern gab es mal eine meldung die
behauptete wissenschaftler hätten
gemessen dass es gar keine erdkrümmung
gäbe dazu gab es ein foto wo eine gruppe
von menschen und messgeräte steht es
leuchtet ein dass das keine wissenschaft
ist dass wir das selbst überprüfen
können und es genügend wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse dazu gibt das die erde eben
nicht flach sondern ein globus ist also
keine wissenschaft check aber auch wenn
ein vogelkundler oder maschinenbauer
sich zum klimawandel äußern dann ist das
keine wissenschaft klar
die beiden haben vom thema eben
offensichtlich keine ahnung es geht aber
noch weiter
wenn ein wissenschaftler nämlich
kaum publiziert oder auch nicht zum
thema publiziert dann ist natürlich
derjenige der sich intensiv mit dem
thema beschäftigt der wissenschaftler
der wahl und jetzt stellt man bei
alexander kekulé fest der publiziert ja
fast gar nicht mehr seit 2017 hat er bis
zum februar diesen jahres nicht
veröffentlicht und bis dahin waren es
lediglich insgesamt 27 wissenschaftliche
arbeiten die in der die us national
library of medizin national institute of
health dem internationalen maßgeblichen
verzeichnis der medizinforschung
aufgeführt sind bei christian drosten
sind es 436 55 aus dem letzten jahr und
46 beschäftigen sich mit dem aktuellen
virus auf zwei beziehungsweise cupid neu
sind also welche expertenmeinung soll
die bundesregierung heranziehen die
antwort liegt denke ich auf der hand da
verstehe ich aber auch die medien nicht
wieso lässt man kekulé als jemanden
dessen fachgebiet corona einfach nicht
ist immer wieder zu wort kommen er ist
sichert dafür gut einfache virologische
sachverhalte in der sesamstraße zu
erklären aber ein corona experte ist
sehr einfach nicht da sollten die medien
einfach mehr verantwortung zeigen wie
beim thema klimawandel bahnt sich immer
wieder gefährliches halbwissen den weg
an die öffentlichkeit und das ist
gefährlich und künstler sind nun
wirklich die falschen absender wenn es
um fakten und wissenschaft bei corona
geht das haben wir ja schon bei alles
dichtmachen eindrücklich vorgeführt
bekommen
aber was diese artikel man leider wieder
mehr als deutlich macht der riss dadurch
die gesellschaft geht und ich sehe es
überhaupt nicht als den zwischen
verantwortungsvollen freiheitsliebenden
fans der demokratie und der passiven
masse die einfach mit macht es geht für
mich dadurch die gesellschaft wo sich
solidarität und egoismus voneinander
trennen und wenn ich mich jetzt nach
meiner corona infektion wieder angstfrei
draußen im öffentlichen leben bewege
dann kraut es mehr menschen stellen sich
in den weg nehmen die maske ab um dosen
leno in der engen u-bahn zu trinken und
und es wäre so schön wenn wir freiwillig
von uns aus rücksicht aufeinander nehmen
würden warum brauchen wir eine
ausgangssperre um nicht andere
menschenleben zu gefährden warum bewegen
wir uns draußen nicht mit abstand und
respekt warum sind so viele menschen
nicht achtsam und machen ihr ding ohne
rücksicht auf
leider im wahrsten sinne des wortes
diese pandemie könnte eine so positive
erfahrung sein könnte das beste im
menschen zum vorschein bringen aber
stattdessen gehen wer wahrsten sinne des
wortes über leichen
wenn wir nämlich dadurch nicht ständig
die zahl der infizierten nach oben
treiben würden dann würden wir auch
nicht teile unserer grundrechte
zeitphase abgenommen bekommen wenn wir
nämlich freiwillig auf ein paar wenige
dinge verzichten würden wäre das alles
nicht nötig ich kann es einfach nicht
verstehen selbst wenn man nicht an die
wirkung von masken glaubt umsetzt wenn
sie nicht wirken lassen wir sie doch
einfach an weil wir den anderen menschen
unseren respekt damit zeigen unsere
solidarität was ist das problem dabei
für mich reicht allein die möglichkeit
dass ich damit am ende der
ansteckungskette irgendjemanden
unbeteiligten töte vollkommen aus das zu
tun und selbst wer an diesen
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
zweifelt lassen wir unsere zweifel doch
bei seite aus respekt vor dem leben und
manche leute sollten deswegen einfach
mal den mund halten künstler und
künstlerinnen zum beispiel dazu welche
maßnahmen jetzt gerechtfertigt sind und
welche nicht selten nur zweifel und
führt damit am ende zu mehr opfern
und selbst wenn was erwiesenermaßen
nicht der fall ist alle maßnahmen nur
ein irrtum wären alleine dass wir
gemeinsam alles unternommen hätten um
menschenleben zu retten wäre doch eine
so schöne botschaft für die menschheit
solche gespräche zu veröffentlichen ist
jedenfalls obszön und verantwortungslos
und das gegenteil von rücksicht in
solidarität mehr ist dazu nicht zu sagen
bis dann bleibt dran